here's a word and you're not gonna like
this word
failure now here's the hitch
it's okay to fail to feel insecure
now composers are arrogant especially
when we're talking about our music
but the fact is the arrogance is
generally hiding great insecurity
you have to let your ego go if you're
smart you're really doing more
listening than talking you really aren't
in charge the director is in charge
your job is to translate their feelings
about their movie into music one more
time
hearing the downbeat bomb
in the course of this master class we're
going to talk about instrumentation
we're going to talk about orchestration
we're going to talk about melody we're
going to talk about a tone
the most important thing you're going to
capture in a film score
is going to be the tone
the unknown known i tried to find a very
simple light motif
guitar there's a mystery to it ostinato
begins
b section and it ends in a classical
after 100 and something films i'm
constantly insecure
doubting yourself finding confidence and
moving forward
and then doubting what you've just done
i think this is the life
of a composer and i think it's the life
of an artist
if you're really gonna succeed there's
no other way but by doing
making mistakes and then learning from
those mistakes and moving on
if you take the time and you learn it i
promise you it'll serve you well
i'm danny elfman and this
is my master class
[Music]
[Applause]
you